[Music]
welcome everyone to streaming the galaxy
my name is rocky riley and today we're
going to be going over everything you
need to know before watching star wars
visions but before we get started if
you're new to the channel please hit the
subscribe button and click the bell icon
to be notified whenever we upload a new
video
now star wars visions is going to be a
series of animated short films
celebrating the star wars galaxy through
the lens of some of the world's best
anime studios with a total of nine
stories from different creators this
anthology collection should bring a new
diverse cultural perspective to the star
wars galaxy the show will air on
wednesday september 22nd on disney plus
and unlike many other new star wars and
marvel tv shows every episode will be
available on the release date so get
ready to binge
the episode lengths have not yet been
released but the titles have starting
off with the duel then lapinacho
tatooine rhapsody the twins the elder
the village bride akakiri tob1 and the
9th jedi
the creative studios for these episodes
are kamikaze duga gino studio sudo
colorito
trigger kinema citrus science saru and
production ig
each of the episodes will have their own
original score some of which will be
uniquely inspired by the john williams
classics ever since the release of the
mandalorian i've been hoping for more
new music from the star wars universe so
this is very exciting for me
for those of you who aren't familiar
with anime or any japanese inspired
stories you may be wondering if you'll
enjoy this show but don't worry even if
you aren't a fan of anime the art styles
of anime will go together with the star
wars storytelling like peanut butter and
chocolate according to james wah the
show's executive producer it sounds like
regardless of your familiarity with
anime the creators believe you'll easily
be able to identify with these new star
wars stories coming from someone with
limited experience in anime titles i'm
very excited to see what the show will
bring to the table
the biggest question most people seem to
have about this show though is is it
canon and the short answer is
no
but i do believe that these stories will
draw upon other ones we have already
come to know and love and i can see
future star wars projects perhaps
mentioning akakiri or some event which
occurs in star wars visions in an
offhand comment or easter egg this
show's main goal is to provide a
landscape for talented artists and story
writers to come together to produce
intriguing and exciting stories without
having to be tied to a canon storyline
or previous character interactions i
believe most if not all of the
characters we see will either be
completely new to the audience or take
an inspirational twist on ones we have
seen before
james hua again said we were looking for
something from the heart and soul of the
individual creators they are their
visions through the lens of star wars
lucasfilm also recently announced a new
book titled ronin a visions novel with
the release date of october 12th this
novel will expand upon the story in the
visions episode the duel following an
unnamed sith samurai wandering the
galaxy written by emma miko ken don this
story will likely end up being
referenced in future star wars titles
and that's everything we know so far and
everything you need to know before
watching star wars visions when it's
released later this month
if you enjoyed today's video please
consider dropping a like and if you have
ideas that you'd like to share for
future videos please drop them in the
comments section below
also don't forget to subscribe for more
great content
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
you